First of all
, thanks to the charcoal fire, it's fragrant and rich.
What I couldn't do was the
sweet chestnuts, so the deliciousness was realized I
chopped the sweet chestnuts and
sprigged some roses too.  I see.
You succeeded in spreading a faint sweetness to the whole deer meat. I was
surprised, but why
?  I'm
going to go with coffee Coffee.
Nirensho sauce is perfect for its deep richness and astringency
, so I tried to use it as a secret
ingredient.
Combining these to create a three-dimensional harmony is
Clenci's.
This dish is the end
of the season
.
Well, it's not that the elements that can be recognized as French have been arranged in their own
way.